yes it is our food truck Friday the
series continues today and you know what
it's a little stormy outside if you
hadn't noticed that we decided to bring
the food truck inside thank you for
coming inside
thank you all right so joining us right
now is Jose Louis Alvarez owner chef
from Louie Louie and Ozzy's running the
show as well he's here with us as well
Ozzy welcome thanks for your coming in
guys appreciate it thank you thank you
for having us today all right so let's
talk about Louie Louie yeah the food
truck how long you guys been around for
uh we've been around since 2019 2019
started uh with an idea of my uncle he
decided to come up with the Hibachi and
a Japanese a food truck in future I
should say it you said it was kind of a
Mexican Japanese Fusion right it is
okay more in our sushi rolls uh mostly
or hibachi you know it comes with your
fried rice your protein and then of your
certified vegetables but um yeah this uh
it's pretty much Mexican and Japanese
well I'm curious because you said Sushi
and then you're saying you know Mexican
Japanese Fusion so how do you make a
sushi roll with that Mexican flavor I
should say mostly because of the spice
the spices the sauces we do it a bit
differently
um and yeah under sauces I feel like we
implement it more in the flavor with it
it gets a good combination with it so
you guys have been around here we're at
the USA Mexico soccer game last night
you said you were at EDC
where are some of the places that you
guys uh can be found around the valley
oh uh so our food trucks located on
Charleston and Rainbow uh right off the
corner of like a little gas station it's
like a little below uh but um we're
gonna open up well we're gonna go back
to it in September because we know we
have a bunch of events lined up but um
another location
um it's on Craig and Rancho exact
location is 4408 North Rancho Drive and
that's the restaurant yes that's the
restaurant okay so you started as a food
truck and then you said you know what
this is going so well we're going to
expand you build a restaurant
congratulations thank you and and of
course Louie that does everybody call
you Louie Louie is that how this started
actually my name is Jose Luis but
everybody call me Luis Luis and then
customers that come to me and say hello
and then Louie Louise come on
yeah sushi for breakfast why not we're
not complaining I'm just curious Ozzy
maybe you can answer this you know we
were talking with a couple other food
trucks for this segment here what's the
what is the demand for food trucks right
now in Las Vegas people go around they
can see them lunchtime and dinners and
so forth but what's the the craving in
the valley right now four food trucks
like yours oh I think it's
big demand the flavor and then uh pretty
much yeah I feel like it's a big demand
in food trucks it's like very convenient
you know you could just park it anywhere
and you know do like little pop-ups I
should say uh yeah if I feel like it's
uh yeah it's going good yeah well okay
so you've got um somebody you know you
want to come and get one of these what
are we talking price point here oh price
points where do we start so we pretty
much start with our you know our lowest
one which is the chicken 16 and we could
go up all the way to like 38. I don't
think you have like the highest quality
so like lobster filet and we uh we do
offer salmon or scallops as well oh boy
but uh you know these are higher plates
yeah we didn't even show off the log
Lobster so that I mean that's a huge
thing right there yeah Lobster well sure
come and join us here Sherry's got the
chopsticks
out right now there we go
all right so what should we try first
you got all this good looking food and
nobody nobody is eating what's going on
should we try first
um
oh yours fell apart all right
and what is this now watch this room I'm
watching shrimp okay
vegetables then shrimp as well
one of the food trucks around the valley
we're going to be profiling food trucks
across the valley weeks and weeks and
weeks yummy and you can try tasting
goodies just like this yeah thanks guys
for coming in appreciate it that is
excellent cheers
thanks so much for joining us here this
morning we know you've got a lot it's
rainy be careful out on the roads and
enjoy your Father's Day weekend and the
golden knights parade tomorrow we'll see
you out there